einem forschungsteam ist es jetzt
gelungen zum ersten mal das menschliche
gehirn mit dem internet zu verbinden und
zwar in echtzeit und dauerhaft und in
zukunft sondern dann auch wirklich daten
auf unser gehirn übertragbar sein
auch wir dann überhaupt noch interfaces
wie smartphones und computer und was
passiert dann wenn wir mit dem ganzen
wissen verbunden sind das erfahrt ihr
jetzt paar klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
es klingt nach science fiction chor aber
forschungsteams und unternehmen weltweit
tüfteln mit hochdruck daran das
menschliche gehirn direkt mit computern
und vor allem auch mit dem internet zu
verbinden nicht nur facebook ist da dran
sondern auch der unternehmer ihren mast
mit seiner firma neuerer link über die
haben wir ja vor kurzem heftig zum
science fiction ausführlicher berichtet
in seinen vorstellungen können wir in
einigen jahrzehnten elektronische geräte
direkt mit unserem gehirn verbinden und
zwar mit hilfe implantierter chips im
hirn die bits und bytes in gedanken über
setzen können und umgekehrt
auf facebook hat ähnliche pläne menschen
sollen demnächst direkt aus dem gehirn
heraus worte im computer schreiben
lassen
100 worte pro minute seien das ziel eine
textnachricht zu schicken ohne dabei das
smartphone aus der tasche zu holen
das hatte facebook im vergangenen jahr
auf der entwicklerkonferenz f8 in
kalifornien bekannt gegeben das
unternehmen beruft sich auf forschung an
der stanford university bei denen eine
gelähmte frau acht worte pro minute in
den computer eingeben kann bohlen große
elektroden im gehirn erkennen die
aktivität der neuronen wenn sie einen
bestimmten buchstaben tippen wollen das
forschungsteam von facebook sei nun
dabei sehr empfindliche sensoren zu
entwickeln die die aktivitäten im gehirn
sehr genau verfolgen können
so wäre es dann auch nicht mehr
notwendig die einzelnen buchstaben im
kopf zu bilden was zu dem auch dazu
führen können dass wir bald auch andere
sprachen sprechen können und zwar ohne
sie vorher zu lernen der gedanke an ein
behälter in der hand aus dem man
flüssigkeit trinken kann könnte dann
direkt mit dem entsprechenden fremdwort
für tasse auf japanisch oder englisch
umgesetzt werden was bereits heute schon
funktioniert ist die kommunikation
zwischen zwei menschen die hirnströme
über das internet austauschen
dies ist ein forschungsteam aus
washington schon vor drei jahren
gelungen da habe auch darüber berichtet
der ist proband mit einer
die kappe auf dem kopf bekam alle
möglichen dinge auf einem bildschirm
gezeigt zum beispiel tiere oder gebäude
der zweite proband saß in einem anderen
raum und sollte herausfinden welche
dinge seine mitstreiter gerade gezeigt
worden waren dazu konnte er fragen
stellen indem er das betreffende bild
mit einem cursor berührt dabei seinen
kollegen blinken dadurch zwei lampen in
unterschiedlicher frequenz eines für die
antwort ja eines für ein proband 1
musste dann nur noch das richtige licht
anschauen dann wurden seine gehirnströme
in ein digitales signal übersetzt und
über das internet an den fragesteller
rüber geschickt und der dann wiederum
seine haube aktivierte so wurde ein
magnetfeld in seinem sehzentrum in der
großhirnrinde stimuliert und er sei
nicht wenn die antwort ja lautete auch
wenn es kein echtes licht war doch für
seine neuronen ja macht das keinen
unterschied die trefferquote des
experiments lag bei 72 schon ziemlich
wahnsinnig ein weiteres projekt
menschliche gehirne mit dem internet zu
verbinden hat jetzt vor kurzem erste
erfolgs ergebnisse geliefert ein
forschungsteam aus johannesburg hat die
elektrischen impulse des gewinns per
livestream an eine website übertragen
also in echtzeit und ständig also auch
unterwegs das ganze nennt sich brain
internet funktioniert so die
testpersonen tragen ein gerät das ein
eeg aufzeichnet also die elektrische
aktivität des gehirns und diese dann
grafisch darstellt die idee signale
werden an einen raspberry pi computer
weitergeleitet der sie wiederum an eine
programmierschnittstelle übergibt durch
die verwendung eines codes ist es dem
programm möglich mit anderen programmen
zu kommunizieren und so konnten die
daten an eine webseite weitergeleitet
werden zusammengefasst wurden hier also
menschliche gehirn aktivitäten über ein
technisches medium an das internet
übertragen und in echtzeit und dauerhaft
und es geht noch weiter denn die
beteiligten forschern behaupten sogar
dass in naher zukunft das auch andersrum
funktionieren wird das also daten und
informationen voll an computer ins
menschliche gehirn übertragen werden
teils dies alles funktioniert ja wird es
die welt wie wir sie kennen komplett
umkrempeln anstatt eine e mail zu tippen
würde es ausreichend einfach kurz an den
gewünschten inhalt zu denken
der computer verwandelt unsere gedanken
dann in entsprechenden text zudem hätten
wir zugriff auf gedanken und erfahrungen
anderer menschen so könnten wir also
problemlos die erfahrung von anderen
erleben zb die eines promis oder eines
soldaten
auch wenn wir bestimmt das fachwissen
haben wollen müssen wir nur an den
wunschdenken und könnten schon die
gedanken entsprechender expertinnen und
experten herunterladen
doch natürlich gibt es auch hier wieder
mögliche negative oder sogar fatale
folgen denn wer garantiert uns dann dass
gedanken nicht einfach wahllos gelesen
werden bzw
mit anderen geteilt werden klingt alles
nach science-fiction pur und viel
experte und experten zweifeln noch an
der umsetzbarkeit dieser vision den
sechs supercomputer sind jetzt hat
lediglich in der lage wenige sekunden
die aktivitäten des menschlichen gehirns
aufzuzeichnen fest steht jedenfalls noch
einen schritt weiter und schon sind wir
bei einer der drei visionen des
sogenannten transform annis muss der
digitale neue mensch auch upload
bezeichnet diese vision ist ziemlich
radikal denn demnach wird das
bewusstsein des menschen durch eine
vollständige digitalisierung
transformiert der name dieses prozesses
hohe brain relations oder auch ab
loading das gehirn wird hier also quasi
als austauschbare hardware definiert
mensch und maschine haben sich dann so
angenähert dass eine digitale kopie von
personen möglich ist eben wie ein
download der identität unsere jeweilige
gehirn software kann dann auf avatare
überspielt werden ja also das ist noch
zukunftsmusik aber das andere das hat
schon stattgefunden das werden also
erhebliche fortschritte erzielt und die
daten zwischen hirn und internet werden
immer genauer übertragen einerseits ja
andererseits ein bisschen spooky können
dann gehirn in zukunft gehackt werden
und was passiert wenn gehirne mit
künstlicher intelligenz verknüpft werden
da gibt es eine menge technischer aber
auch moralischer fragen wenn er keine
videos zum vernetzen werden und zu allen
anderen dem verpassen wollt dann endet
mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die
kaputte abo box hier auf youtube und
verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp
der von mir noch vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video täglich garantiert
einfach draufklicken und am besten auch
meine schwester kammer klicks um social
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür ihr
klicken aber nicht die immer wieder
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
darf auch draufklicken künstliche
intelligenz entwickelt sich immer
schneller
bis dahin bleibt dran